Demi Lovato's sister Madison De La Garza
celebrates her sobriety try to show
people that hey
um there's so much more to life when you
take care of yourself from when you're
able to to be the best that you can be
the 21 year old shared this Tick Tock
revealing she's 230 days sober adding
the hashtag recovery is possible
Madison didn't specify what she stopped
using but in January she shared this
video featuring a filter that read I'm
quitting leaves emoji in seven seconds
the Emoji known to refer to marijuana
what keeps me on this path is
I don't know there's a drive that I have
to stay sober because I know that my
life depends on it it's something that
if I would have continued down that road
it would have been I don't know if I'd
be here today sobriety is a subject
close to home for Demi as they've been
open about their own Journey it's
something that's very important to me
and then I've been able to share my
story with other people and I've had
fans that come up to me and tell me you
know because you got sober I got sober
and um it's just been a really beautiful
day but in July 2018 Demi faced a
setback when they experienced a near
fatal opioid overdose even going into
detail about it in their docu-series
Demi Lovato dancing with the devil I
actually don't think people realize how
bad it actually was
I had three Strokes
I had a heart attack
I suffered brain damage from The Strokes
I can't drive anymore and for Madison
it's a time she'll never forget and I
said I'm here and I love you just to let
her know I had gotten to the hospital
and she looked me dead in the eye and
she said who is that
[Music]
something you never want to hear your
sister say there have been a couple
times where I thought
if that's how she wants to go out then
God damn it let her go out that way but
I don't think you truly ever really give
up on someone like that I think it's
important for me to talk about my
so that more people don't feel alone in
their experiences fast forward five
years and Demi's ready for their next
chapter their 30s what I'm looking for
is you know looking people straight in
the eyes not spending too much time on
my phone and the distractions that we
have in our everyday life you know it's
important for me to go sit in the grass
and enjoy the Sun the singer turned the
big 3-0 in August and told ET their
secret to balancing life you know
there's things like meditation there's
things like working with a spiritual
coach and also just staying true to who
you are and you know standing on your
own two feet and
staying strong and like I said true to
who you are what's cool about that is
I've really figured out who I am and I
say that a lot every every time I get
older you know but it's like I've never
felt so sure of myself and grounded
[Music]
thank you